[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans élémentaire
l'émission de Public Sénat qui essaie de
donner de la perspective et de la
profondeur de champ aux éléments de
l'actualité cependant que Donald Trump
recueille 55 % des intentions de vote
aux États-Unis girt wildilders a
remporter les législatives au Pays-Bas
et jaavier mi a été élu président de
l'Argentine évidemment chaque situation
nationale est particulière mais ces
hommes ont tous en commun de se réclamer
du peuple contre les élites de priser la
démocratie directe de pratiquer le culte
du chef et d'aimer aussi les vérités
alternatives les fake news comme on dit
bref d'être catalogué comme populiste
qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement
populiste qu'est-ce que ça recouvre quel
est quels sont les facteurs les ressorts
du développement du populisme quel est
l'avenir du populisme c'est de cela dont
nous allons discuter ce soir dans cette
émission que nous avons intitulé
l'irrésistible ascension du populisme
mais avec un point d'interrogation et
pour nous aider dans cette tâche deux
esprits éclairés Pascal Perino bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes professeur de sciences
politiques vous êtes un spécialiste
notamment de l'extrême droite et vous
avez longtemps dirigé le Centre de
Recherche politique de Sciences Po vous
avez écrit en particulier un que sais-je
sur le populisme Marc Lazar bonsoir vous
êtes professeur d'histoire et de
sociologie politique également à
sciencep vous êtes à la fois un
spécialiste de la gauche notamment du
Parti communiste et vous êtes un
spécialiste aussi de l'Italie qui a
désigné un chef de gouvernement issu de
la droite populiste euh madame Georgia
melony nous allons essayer ensemble de
comprendre de de de définir la notion
d'abord euh de d'essayer de comprendre
les ressorts de l'ascension du populisme
et puis de voir quelles sont ses
perspectives mais on va commencer par la
définition Pascal Perino on a parfois le
sentiment que populisme c'est un concept
Fourtout qui rassemble des des forces
disparaîtes est-ce qu'il y a une
définition canonique et clair pour
regrouper ces phénomènes oui comme tous
les concepts qui connaissent de la
réussite pas simplement dans le monde
intellectuel mais dans l'espace public
en effet peu à peu ce sont des concepts
qui deviennent confus mais si on veut
essayer d'y voir clair
au fond le populisme ce sont deux
éléments deux choses c'est d'abord une
lecture de la société tout à fait
particulière qui considère que les
sociétés sont divisées entre un peuple
homogène alors le principe d'homogénéité
peut-être différent selon le type de
populisme mais entre un peuple homogène
et des élites elles-mêm homogènees
c'estàd c'est une vision très binaire de
la société avec deux acteurs qui ont une
forte homogénéité interne et puis après
cet élément de lecture de la société il
y a un deuxième élément euh qui est au
fond le mode d'action du populisme le
mode d'action du populisme c'est de
considérer que ce peuple homogène se
retrouve en un leader
charismatique qui parle tout haut ce que
le peuple pense tout bas par-dessus la
tête des intermédiaires euh dans un
phénomène qui est un phénomène de
démocratie quasi directe qui joue dans
les deux sens le leader que ce soit un
homme ou une femme d'ailleurs parle le
peuple et le leader consulte le peuple
en permanence c'est vrai que le
populisme a réhabilité d'une certaine
manière les instruments de la démocratie
directe mais Marc euh en même temps il y
a une distinction entre un populisme de
droite et un populisme de gauche don
qu'est-ce que ces deux populismes ont en
commun et qu'est-ce qui les distingue
alors euh effectivement on peut adhérer
tout à fait à la définition qu'a donné
Pascal du populisme on peut rajouter
aussi que le populistme c'est un certain
style euh il y a des populistes qui
veulent absolument échapper à une
distinction droite et gauche par exemple
on a eu un très bon exemple avec
l'Italie le mouvement 5 étoiles était en
fait ni de droite ni de gauche et puis
la majorité des populismes en tout cas
en Europe sont plutôt à droite et une
minorité à gauche alors qu'est-ce qu'on
entend par là mais ils ont des points
communs effectivement la détestation des
élites en Europe la critique de l'Union
européenne l'appel au peuple direct un
certain style effectivement deune
manière de se parler y compris à travers
le gestuel le parfois le langage
corporel de ses leaders et cetera mais
ils ont en même temps des différences
des différences sur le contenu d'abord
du peuple c'est pas le même type de
peuple le peuple des populistes de
droite très souvent c'est les gens bon
le populisme de gauche normalement c'est
plutôt le peuple politique c'est une
dimension surtout en France un peu
jacobine du peuple c'est le peuple
avant-garde le peuple qui est conscient
politiquement ce qui n'empêchait pas
pour prendre un cas concret Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de mélanger à la fois le
peuple au sens politique moi j'appelle
ça le populous en la latin à la plepse
c'est-à-dire aux gens il combinai les
deux choses ils ont des différences
aussi en terme de sociologie c'est pas
le même type d'électorat ils ont pas la
même conception aussi très souvent de la
nation ils se réfèrent tous les deux à
la nation mais d'un côté c'est une
nation plutôt fermée c'est le populisme
de droite et et du populisme de gauche
c'est une nation ouverte donc point
commun et divergence dans un petit livre
qui avait été écrit dirigé par le
regrettter Daniel Cohen il disait en
gros ils ont en commun le avec la
détérioration du bien-être mais ce qui
les distingue c'est que les populistes
de gauche conservent une vision
solidaire de la société par exemple
nonont pas hosilité aux immigrés alors
que les populistes de droite sont
méfiants enfin organisent la la méfiance
de chacun vis-à-vis de tous cette
question de défiance est fondamentale
elle a été très bien mise en lumière par
justement Daniel Cohen Yan AlGaN et
d'autres chercheurs les deux populismes
ont partage une défiance verticale
contre les élites contre les
institutions mais ils n'ont pas le même
type de défiance horizontale à droite
c'est une défiance je me défie je me
méfie de l'étranger même de mon voisin
tandis que l'électeur du populisme de
gauche lui a une grande confiance à
l'égard du voisin et même à l'égard de
l'étranger Pascal est-ce qu'on peut dire
d'une manière un peu paradoxale que au
fond si je compare le populisme de
droite madame mélonie par exemple et les
partis fascistes italiens d'autrefois
l'extrême droite traditionnelle ou en
France Marine Le Pen et ce quiétait son
père ou à gauche la nupesse si elle est
populiste versus qu' a été le communiste
stalinien est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'au
fond le populisme est un progrès une
démocratisation des forces d'opposition
j'aurais plutôt tendance à répondre de
manière un peu lapidaire plutôt oui si
vous voulez le le le populisme c'est pas
le fascisme le populisme ça n'est pas le
communisme hein si on donne au
communisme et au fascisme des
définitions sérieuses dans la rue bien
sûr on peut crier FN F comme fasciste n
comme nazi mais bon voilà là on est on
cherche à réfléchir euh donc je crois
que le populisme à cet égard est très
différent du fascisme et du communisme
parce que quelque part il a intégré une
partie du logiciel démocratique ces
partis ne prétendent pas par exemple au
parti unique que ce soit le parti
communiste ou le parti fasciste ils ne
prétendent absolument pas à cela ils
sont très loin par exemple des rêves
d'une économie corporatiste qui était
les rêves de l'économie fasciste ou
d'une économie
totalement nationalisé comme les
communistes ont pu en rêver donc il y a
oui de vraies différences et quelque
part le populisme dans une période de de
crise de la politique pose la question
démocratique à nouveau il y apporte des
réponses que l'on peut considérer comme
étant tout à fait excessive maladroite
contestable mais il pose la question
démocratique parce que il pose la
question de la place du Peuple des gens
d'en bas dans le procè essus
démocratique et il pose également la
question de l'essoufflement de la
démocratie représentative et de la
nécessité peut-être à côté du processus
de la démocratie représentative et de
l'élection d'inventer d'autres modes
d'expression démocratique d'autres modes
d'intervention du peuple dans la vie
politique alors ça nous conduit un
deuxième chapitre qui sont vous les avez
abordé d' C manière les les les les
ressorts les ressorts de cette de cette
montée du du populisme il y a TR
ressorts sur lesquel je voudrais qu'on
revienne un ressort matériel un ressort
spirituel ou intellectuel culturel et un
ressort démocratique donc premier point
matériel est-ce que la la crise
économique entre guillemets de
l'Occident qui n'est pas une crise mais
qui disons le ralentissement de la
croissance le sentiment d'une
insuffisance de distribution de pouvoir
d'achat est-ce que c'est ça qui est le
facteur décisif qui explique la montée
depuis une vingtaine d'années ou une
trentaine d'années du populisme c'est un
des facteurs c'est pas le facteur des
décisif mais c'est incontestablement un
des facteurs il y a évidemment le
chômage mais on voit qu' des pays où le
chômage est très réduit la Suisse par
exemple où il y a toujours eu un parti
populiste extraordinairement fort la
Pologne il y a quelques années avait un
taux de croissance très important un
chômage très réduit et pourtant il y
avait un populisme fort la France
actuellement a une grande diminution de
son chômage et ça n'empêche pas le
développement du populisme mais
incontestablement il y a un élément
socio-économique lié donc au chômage aux
inégalités incontestablement aussi à des
poches aussi de de pauvreté et puis
alors là dans ces dernières années la
question du pouvoir d'achat et
l'inflation d'ailleurs c'est un des
thèmes de préoccupation fondamentale en
France c'est une des priorités en
général que disent les Français beaucoup
plus par exemple que la question de
l'immigration même s'ils sont sensibles
à la question de l'immigration je
remarque aussi qu'en Italie très souvent
on a dit en 2022 lorsque Georgia melony
avec la coalition l'a emporté en France
on a dit c'est à cause du thème des
migrants et d'immigration oui et non
l'autre thème fondamental c'était
justement la question du pouvoir d'achat
de l'inflation et du prix de
l'électricité du gaz qui est qui était à
l'époque extraordinairement élevé pour
l'Italie donc c'est un des facteurs et
j'ajouterai un autre élément qui touche
notamment les jeunes et notamment les
femmes aussi c'est la question de la
précarisation du marché du travail parce
qu'on peut très bien dire il y a un
faible taux de chômage mais ça
s'accompagne effec des petits jobs des
précarisations de marché du travail qui
suscitent l'inquiétude de ceux qui sont
confrontés les jeunes et encore plus de
leurs parents qui considèrent que leurs
enfants nmalement pas la même chance que
eux ont eu à l'époque de ce qu'on a
appelé les glorieuse alors l'autre thème
qui qui souvent apparaît comme bien plus
important c'est le sentiment qui donne
c'est pas le la question de du regret du
niveau de vie d'avant c'est la question
du regret du style de vie d'avant c'est
la crise de l'identité des sociétés
occidentale et notamment en raison de la
question de l'immigration bien sûr c'est
le sentiment qu'un vieux monde se défait
un vieux monde que l'on fantasme un
petit peu tout de même euh parce qu'il
pouvait être dur le vieux monde aussi
mais un vieux monde sur lequel se
développe toute une nostalgie je crois
et vous le disiez dans votre
introduction deis tout à l'heure il y a
une dimension mondiale à ce phénomène
c'est pas simplement la France l'Europe
c'est une dimension mondiale vous citiez
l'Argentine on pourrait citer l'Inde de
maudit enfin voilà hein c'est le monde
entier qui est saisi par cela et je
crois qu'il y a un nouveau clivage dans
les sociétés en réponse à cet enjeu
massif sur lequel on a beaucoup insisté
à juste titre qui est la globalisation
c'est vrai que nos sociétés sont
beaucoup plus ouverte que ce soit à
l'est à l'ouest au nord ou au sud
qu'elle ne pouvait l'être il y a encore
30 ans ou 50 ans cette ouverture elle
est économique on a vu avec Marc de
manière excellente là les différents
facteurs de cette économie ouverte qui
pose qui pose de réels problèmes et en
particulier aux gens de peu comme disait
pierre sanau mais l'ouverture elle a
aussi un autre visage elle a le visage
des sociétés qui deviennent de plus en
plus mêlé cosmopolites hein dans lequel
les autres euh sont de plus en plus
visibles et bien sûr l'autre la figure
essentielle de l'autre c'est l'immigré
parce que l'immigré quelque part
pourquoi on parle autant d'immigration
c'est parce que l'immigré c'est la
figure de la société ouverte c'est
l'homme qui passe les frontières pour
les immigrés clandestin hein qui va et
qui revient c'est le symbole de cette
société ouverte que certains en ce
moment de manière massive sont en train
de rejeter parce qu'ils considèrent que
on a plus à perdre qu'à gagner à cette
société ouverte et qu'il ne s'y
retrouveve pas parce que pour eux la
société ouverte ça dissou ce que l'on
était ça dissous nos racines et puis
aussi il y a toujours je crois dans le
le populisme un facteur politique
essentiel l'ouverture sans qu'on s'en
rende compte c'est une ouverture
politique la démocratie elle s'exprime
elle s'exprimera dans les décennies qui
viennent essentiellement dans le cadre
national mais vous voyez bien que tous
les jours ceux qui décident de notre
sort c'est de plus en plus plus de la
gouvernance supranationale c'est
l'Europe c'est les instruments de
gouvernance mondiale le FMI et cetera et
là les gens ont la pression aussi d'un
sentiment mais phénoménal de
dépossession et c'est tout cela si vous
la perte d'un patrimoine comme le dit
Dominique rier à juste titre d'un
patrimoine immatériel auquel pour de
bonnes ou de mauvais raison les gens
sont attachés et le facteur commun vous
venez de l'évoquer on l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est aussi la crise du des
mécanismes de prentation de la crise de
la
démocratie à la fois la crise de la
démocratie la société de l'information
le développement des réseaux sociaux ce
qui nourrit me semble-t-il mais c'est
vous je voudis entendre ce qui nourrit
le populisme vous disiez tout à l'heure
l'un et l'autre que le peuple ne se sent
plus représenté utilement dans la
société c'est bien ça qui est le le le
le les mécanismes que nous avons inventé
disons au 17e ou 18e siècle paraissent
ne plus fonctionner pour donner le
sentiment de la représentation
démocratique oui incontestablement il y
a une fatigue et a un épuisement de de
la force propulsive de la démocratie
libérale et représentative
incontestablement d'autant plus que
c'est populistes il y a une grande
différence historique vous l'avez
comparé on l'a comparé à juste raison au
fascisme au communisme mais quand on
prend les expériences passées du
populisme prenons la France le
boulangisme à la fin du 19e siècle le
poujadisme dans les années 50 ce sont
des populistes qui sont qui se
prononcent pour des régimes de type
autoritaire dé facto ils veulent un
renforcement énorme du pouvoir exécutif
voire à travers une personne aujourd'hui
la grande force de ces populistes c'est
de se présenter comme les meilleurs des
démocrates qui n'ont pas peur du peuple
et ça c'est un un pavé dans la marre des
partis traditionnels donc c'est c'est un
élément important et effectivement il
joue sur un autre point c'est
effectivement la la crise de la
représentation qui est amplifiée par la
défiance de plus en plus forte d'une
grande partie de la société à l'égard
des politiques et j'ajouteraiis aussi il
faut le dire une défiance des élites par
rapport au peuple je ne dis pas qu'on
est à la situation du 19e siècle où il y
avait la peur des furies populaires mais
il y a quand même une défiance
aujourd'hui d'une grande partie des
élites sur mais qu'est-ce que va faire
ce ce peuple et le tout se joue
effectivement à l'URE des chaînes
d'informationue des réseaux sociaux et
qui a instauré une nouvelle forme de
démocratie qui est la démocratie de
l'urgence et et et ça de l'instant euh
donc c'est plus simplement la démocratie
du public comme disait notre ami Bernard
Manin c'est la démocratie de l'urgence
et ça c'est tout à fait fondamental
parce que les populistes du coup
proposent une forme d'absence de
médiation à travers l'incarnation du
leader et à travers l'urgence comment
régler la question d'immigration il y a
qu' il y a qu' disait melony faire un
blocus naval puis elle arrive au pouvoir
et résultat elle en accepte 450000
aujourd'hui parce que le patronat le
demande on va revenenir à ça mais est-ce
que ça nous conduit au fond au 3è
chapitre que je voulais qu'on évoque
ensemble qui est où ça va où tout ça
nous conduit mais est-ce que cette cette
exigence de
l'immédiateté de l'action immédiate et
de la représentation immédiate du peuple
n'est pas radicalement compatible avec
la gestion et la transformation d'une
société et la gestion de ces des des des
des sujets qui lui sont posés tout à
fait il y a une question de rapport au
temps la représentation c'est du temps
long h le populisme c'est du temps
extrêmement court c'est ils sont adaptés
hein à l'urgentisme au temps immédiat
voilà il y a un malaise bien le leader
va dire le malaise du peuple et cetera
il y a un problème l'immigration faisons
un référendum voyez et cetera donc euh
c'est vrai que la performance populiste
est très liée à cette accélération du
temps sur lequel des tas de
d'intellectuels ont dit des choses
extrêmement intéressantes dans la
période récente et puis si vous voulez
il faut bien reconnaître que la crise de
la politique a débouché maintenant sur
un vrai phénomène c'est plus
d'indifférence c'est de la haine de la
politique on l'a vu très bien dans ce
populisme social qui a été le mouvement
des gilets jaunes parce que le mouvement
des gilets jaunes qu'est-ce que c'est on
a parlé du populisme politique
strictoinsu mais c'est le mouvement
social saisi par le populisme hein plus
aucune organisation syndicale une espèce
de spontanéité de la base le refus de
toute représentation le vieux
tempérament roussoïste qui consiste à
dire au fond mais la souveraineté
nationale elle ne peut pas être
représentée hein il y aurait qu'une
seule démocratie qui vaille c'est la
démocratie directes vous savez en France
c'est un tempérament de longue durée
cette affaire et et là faut reconnaître
les populistes sont plus adaptés à cela
et tout cela est réactivé par
l'atmosphère de crise de multicrise dans
lesquell nous sommes les populistes sont
beaucoup plus adaptés à ça que les
parties classiques et traditionnelles
qui sont très très empétrés qui ne ne
savent pas s'adapter à la nouvelle donne
mais du coup du coup est-ce que c'est
une question que je vous pose à tous les
deux est-ce que du coup il y a pas une
contamination de cette de ce populisme
aux partis de gouvernement traditionnel
qui eux-mêmes se se s'engagent dans dans
une tentative pour pour gérer à très
court terme de manière immédiate les
questions qui appellent pourtant des
solutions de long terme mais exactement
c'est tout ce qui se passe en ce moment
je crois qu'il faut plus analyser
simplement les mouvements populistes ou
les partis populistes en eux-même mais
sur l'impact qu'ils ont dans tout le
reste de la société dans la vie
politique c'est qu'ils imposent leur
tempo ils imposent leurs thématiqu ils
imposent leurs agendas et ils mettent
les partis traditionnels ou les hommes
ou les femmes politiques traditionnelles
représentants de ces partis dans une
situation très compliquée parce que où
on utilise un certain style populiste
pour gagner on a deux exemples je vais
vous en donner ou alors on fait
exactement l'opposé deux exemples de
style populiste Emmanuel Macron en
2016-27 c'est un style ça veut pas dire
qu'il est populiste sur le fond mais il
se présente comme un candidat nouveau
antiystème qui contournera les
organisations syndicales les mairies et
cetera qui défendent leurs propres
intérêts et lire le chapitre dans
révolution son livre sur les partis
politiques par exemple ou Matthéo Renzi
en Italie centregauche qui essae par ce
style d'appel direct au peuple de
prendre des voies 5 étoiles et puis il y
a à l'opposé consiste à dire ben on va
pas rentrer là-dedans et moi je vois
deux exemples en Europe historique alors
Angela Merkel alors bien sûr elle
n'avait pas le même type de challenge
populiste de défi populiste face à elle
mais qui dit je ne céderai pas je
continuerai en fonction de ce que je
crois et puis l'autre en Italie celui
qui a batttu deux fois Berlusconi et qui
est Romano Prodi qui a tout fait pour ne
pas jouer sur le terrain de Silvio
Berlusconi parce qu'il savait qu'il
serait perdu donc il jouait au
professeur peut-être un peu ennuyeux
mais sur lequel il affirmé à chaque fois
ce qu'il pouvait dire et ce qu'il
pouvait faire a gagné deux fois Pascal
vous considérez que l'erreur des partis
traditionnelles a été précisément de ne
pas se différencier il y a une espèce de
de de course à l'échalote dans lequel
ils perdront toujours jouer au
populistes on n'y croit pas quand Macron
joue au populiste étant donné ce qu'il
est un homme issu de la haute fonction
publique et cetera passer par les
meilleures écoles mais c'est pas
crédible vous voyez ça sent le pastiche
quand Eric cotti joue au populiste ben
voilà on n'y croit pas non plus donc ils
sont perdants avant même d'avoir
commencé et donc il il faudrait que les
partis traditionnels trouvent un style
alors ce style est est-il le style d'une
certaine rigueur par exemple que prodie
a pu a pu incarner en Italie mais
regardez ce qui vient de se passer parce
que voyez en reprenons le titre de votre
émission l'irrésistible montée du du
populisme point d'interrogation oui il y
a une une montée elle est peut-être
résistible elle semble irrésistible
statistiquement mais il y a des pays qui
échappent regardez ce qui vient de se
passé en Pologne hein en Pologne on a
Donald Tusk un homme qui a acquis
beaucoup d'expérience dans les
institutions européenne un homme qui est
d'une grande sérénité d'un bon niveau
intellectuel qui ne joue pas du tout au
populiste et bien Donald Tusk a emporté
à la tête d'une coalition les élections
regardez l'Espagne l'Espagne où tout de
même les partis traditionnels que ce
soit le parti populaire et en
l'occurrence là le Parti socialiste qui
cherche à bricoler en effet mais nous
sommes dans une démocratie parlementaire
hein bon voilà les Français sont pas
habitués à ça mais il de vrai d'ailleurs
peu à peu ils vont découvrir les charmes
de la démocratie parlementaire voilà bon
le Parti socialiste les partis en
Espagne relativement classique se
défendent et et Vox qui est le principal
parti populiste a connu tout de même un
coup d'arrêt donc euh
irrésistible c'est peut-être résistible
est-ce que ça n'est pas bonne nouvelle
est-ce que ça n'est pas marque parce que
l'expérience du pouvoir transforme les
populistes une fois qu'ils sont
confrontés vous on a l'exemple de
l'Italie vous connaissez bien une fois
qu'ils sont confrontés au réel est-ce
qu'ils ne cessent pas est-ce qu'ils ne
deviennent pas à leur tour des des
partis gestionnaires on a deux cas de
figure en Europe en Europe hein le cas
hongrois et là c'est le bouleversement
des institutions c'est la démocratie
libérale de Monsieur Orban
ilbéral illibéral merci ça prouve que
vous
suivez confirme et et Démocratie
libérale qui consiste à dire je fais
voter les populations sachant que la
compétition électorale est biaisée mais
une fois obtenu la majorité des
suffrages je prends le contrôle des
médias de la Cour constitutionnelle
j'impose un certain type de programme
par exemple dans les manuels d'histoire
dans les établissements secondaires je
relis complètement l'histoire de la
Hongrie même chose des atteintes à la
liberté académique dans les universités
et cetera et cetera et puis vous avez le
le cas italien alors il est en cours
mais on a eu l'expérience des
gouvernement ligue mouvement 5 étoiles
et là moi ce qui me frappe c'est la
capacité de résilience des démocraties
parce que on vient de d'insister sur la
crise de la démocratie mais il y a des
capacités de résilience de la démocratie
la preuve c'est que ces formations
populistes aujourd'hui ne sont plus
comme les formations populistes du passé
et dans le cas italien c'est très
intéressant c'est la capacité moi que
j'appelle d'absorption du choc
protestataire et populiste ça a été le
cas à avec la Ligue et mement 5 étoiles
et c'est peut-être le cas c'est pas
gagné mais c'est peut-être le cas de
Georg Mellon on va voir l'enjeu c'est la
réforme constitutionnelle qu'elle engage
avec une volonté d'élire au suffrage
universel le Premier ministre avec une
loi électorale qui donnerait 55 % des
siège à la coalition arver en tête quel
que soit le pourcentage obtenu par cette
coalition qui fait étrangement penser à
des lois électorales qui avaient
instaurer le fascisme je ne dis pas
qu'elle est fascistme mais là il y a un
enjeu mais oui c'est pour ça que moi je
parlerai puisque vous avez expression
irrésistible ascension évidemment je
pense à la pièce de Brecht la résistible
ascension d'Arthur oui qu'il écrit
lorsqu'il est à New York s'interrogant
sur les raisons pourquoi Hitler est
arrivé au pouvoir donc il y a une
résistible ascension mais ça dépendra
aussi de la réponse des démocraties
voilà une excellente conclusion de cette
émission d'un côté oui résistible de
l'autre oui
résistible merci à vous deux cette
émission est arrivée à son terme
j'espère que nous aurons éclairé nos
téléspectateurs sur cette question
complexe et à certains égards
inquiétante euh je vous remercie de vos
lumières je remercie ceux qui nous ont
suivi qui peuvent nous revoir d'ailleurs
sur la plateforme publicsenat sur le
site pardon
publsenat.fr merci à vous tous et
bonsoir